off the back of receiving some
particularly underwhelming reviews film
fans weren't exactly fighting to get
hold of one of these but outside of a
handful of cinemas this
protesters picketing screenings of the
lady of heaven ensuring it is one of the
most talked about films out now
when someone openly expresses their
views uh against let's say you know gay
people then it's homophobia but when it
comes to muslims you know it's freedom
of speech and muslims are really fed up
and you know we do not go around
insulting others and we expect you know
mutual respect from others as well
the british made undertaking has proven
provocative from those who believe it's
stoking up sectarian division a shia
filmmaker's controversial take on early
sunni muslim leaders we haven't done
anything actually wrong here it's just
about how people want to interpret
history to be honest first and foremost
in the hands of each individual to act
responsibly and welcome different views
of course at the centre of this is a
battle between respect for religion and
freedom of speech just recently russia
today had its broadcast license revoked
over the language it used to describe
the war in ukraine so undeniably that
freedom can come with caveats now in the
uk what we don't have is a blasphemy law
what we do have is cancel culture
while whoever shouts the loudest might
make headlines aisha ali khan a writer
who's sunni and has seen the film
believes in reality this is only driving
ticket sales
it's very offensive um likely to cause
great
hurt the main thing that they've done is
just bring a lot more attention to a
film that
would wouldn't really have garnered that
much attention oh now you listen here
it's not the bazaar it's a very naughty
boy one of the most notorious censorship
routes in the uk was back in 1979 the
fallout from monty python's satire on
christianity resulting in some local
council bans and an increased age rating
cinemas which have cancelled the film
say they had to to protect the safety of
staff but in doing so triggering a
censorship controversy that's
potentially even more dangerous
benson sky news